no no
[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio moro
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español parís la llamada 'ciudad luz'
y las comunas que la rodean viven un
proceso de gran transformación un
proceso de gran calado pues se trata en
pocos años de llevar a cabo lo que se le
conoce como el proyecto del gran parís
un gran proceso de transformación de
remodelación de todas las comunas que
están alrededor de la capital francesa y
que tiene como objetivo ponerla a nivel
de las megalópolis como son nueva york o
tokio teniendo en perspectiva los juegos
olímpicos del 2024 que se desarrollaban
en la capital francesa para hablarnos de
este proceso sin precedentes en la
realización de ese cambio en francia
saludamos aquí en nuestro estudio a
roberto romero aguilar concejal de la
región isla de francia para el proyecto
del gran parís y profesor de economía
roberto bienvenidos a esta escalera ya
es un placer tenerlo con nosotros el
proyecto del gran parís es un programa
muy ambicioso es una remodelación
de organización sin precedentes por lo
menos desde el siglo 19 su objetivo es
promover un nuevo proceso de desarrollo
que incluye cultura que incluye
transporte que incluye educación
alojamiento etcétera como definiría a
usted de manera breve este proyecto
bueno para ser breve yo diría que es que
será necesario
inconcluso y polémico necesario porque
la situación de parís es una situación
que necesitaba tener un desarrollo
amplio e inconcluso porque todavía queda
mucho que hacer incluso dentro de la
gobernabilidad de la estructura y
polémico porque tiene algunas
algunos elementos que todavía no están
muy claros dentro de las prioridades
reales que quiere llevar a cabo el gran
prix cualquier cifra que usemos para
definir este megaproyecto puede parecer
ridículo puede parecer inimaginable
puede darnos algunos ejemplos precisos
de lo que implica este proceso de
transformación bueno para dar una cifra
que pueda ser una cifra que pueda tener
algún sentido por ejemplo en parís hay
225 kilómetros de metro que actualmente
que se construyeron en los 120 años que
empezó el metro en 1900
se trata para el gran parís llevar a
cabo 200 km es decir doblar la capacidad
del metro pero en algunos años es decir
en los 10 años que vienen se tiene que
doblar la capacidad lo que uno imagina
la amplitud y la magnitud del proyecto
ya que parís era y es todavía hoy la
capital que tiene la más grande red y el
más grande masaje de estaciones de metro
del mundo entonces desde ese punto de
vista
uno puede imaginar que construir estar
haciendo galerías subterráneas de 200
kilómetros es algo que de una
envergadura que no tiene precedente en
la historia realmente faraónico como
trabajo y al mismo tiempo usted lo dice
es el mayor masaje y al mismo tiempo es
una las ciudades con mayor densidad de
población del mundo creo que es la
quinta o sexta ciudad del mundo con
mayor densidad de población civil
hispano parís por eso que tenemos un
enfoque específico porque parís como
ciudad son dos millones de habitantes y
tienen una densidad más alta que
shanghai
mundo para darse un poco de tener un
poco esa es la idea y la ciudad ha ido
evolucionando mucho
y
pero sigue siendo una ciudad que ha tira
que está muy atractiva para las empresas
porque justamente porque la movilidad es
relativamente simple hoy en parís que
vive en parís no hay necesidad de
vehículos puede desplazarse en bicicleta
o metro o en bus la dificultad es poder
vivir en parís y eso es otro tema que es
el tema del coste de la vida en parís
que hoy es muy complicado ciertamente y
la otra problema es para una vez que
usted sale un poco de parís es el
problema de la interconectividad entre
ciudades todo mundo está obligado por
pasar por el centro de parís a este
propósito uno de los grandes proyectos
uno de los grandes ejes del proyecto
gran parís es justamente evitar que la
gente tenga que volver a pasar por el
centro de parís es correcto exacto es
decir muchos de los proyectos de metro
que sean que se están realizando hoy
están realizando y hay metros que se van
a abrir en mi ciudad se va a abrir al
final del año de una estación nueva que
va a cambiar totalmente
la identidad de la de la comuna pero van
a tener otras
otras problemáticas pero el hecho era
poder
acabar con la centralidad de parís como
ciudad nudo que además de eso era muy
compleja a nivel del tránsito
y la idea es poder justamente poder
rodear parís el centro de parís para
poder tener un desplazamiento más normal
dentro del balance que se hace entre la
gente que vive al este de parís y que va
a trabajar al oeste porque esa es la
realidad de cuántas personas estamos
hablando que pudieran beneficiarse una
vez concluido este megaproyecto estamos
hablando aquí alrededor de 7 millones de
personas que son la gente que vivían
dentro del metro por el gran parís que
está dibujada hoy
sabiendo que la lógica que habría sido
que habría tenido de tener una
metrópolis a nivel regional tendría que
tocar a 12 millones y eso plantea no
solo el número de personas que están van
a poder beneficiar del gran parís pero
también de los 5 millones que no van a
beneficiar el gran parís que es uno de
los problemas que toca hoy a la capital
a este propósito roberto justamente la
transformación del proyecto gran parís
implica también una redistribución
administrativa y política qué significa
esto de región concretamente como se le
explica a la gente que vive qué es una
región de en francia porque hablamos de
parís hablamos de la región île de
france y ahora estamos hablando del
proyecto gran parís como tal si entonces
la región indo fost lleva e integra ocho
provincias de pacto que serían
embargados departamentos el equivalente
de lo que podrían ser provincias en
algunos otros países y ocho
provincias y dentro de las ocho
provincias está a parís porque parís
tiene una doble entidad o doble digamos
dimensión administrativa es ciudad y
departamento y esas ocho departamentos
constituyen la región y el gran parís
está constituido por parís y tres
departamentos y son los departamentos
que tocan a parís ya que son leds en que
es la sede sandy nin y el baldeo mago
esos son los los tres otros
departamentos que configuran el gran
parís y siete ciudades que están al
límite y que votaron para poder entrar
dentro del gran del gran parís y la
región abarca 12 millones de personas y
dentro de esa región está ahora la
metrópolis del gran parís que son solo
siete y eso es una de las primeras
contradicciones y las polémicas porque
el objetivo era simplificar la
administración y en realidad se ha
agregado un peldaño más entre
entre las estratos de que en el sistema
administrativo francés complicado de
seguir espero que nuestro público pueda
seguir precisamente este juego de cifras
de arreglos entre las regiones ciudades
comunas que no es muy sencillo el
proyecto del gran parís roberto surge
como idea en el 2006-2007 se pone en
práctica a partir del 2016
todo esto evidentemente mucho antes de
que alguien imaginar a por lo menos de
que iba a llegar esta famosa pandemia
que ha golpeado a todo el mundo que está
transformando el mundo en el proyecto
del gran parís se incluían miles de
metros cuadrados para la utilización de
oficinas ahora con la pandemia estamos
viendo cómo se transforma esta situación
en el famoso teletrabajo cómo se
pretende resolver esta esta situación
que no estaba prevista y que implica
millones de espacios de metros que se
pueden quedar masivos bueno para resumir
esquemas y es que matizar un poco el
tema estamos la construcción del gran
parís empezó en un momento en el cual el
modelo económico era lo que era
y la pandemia vino a chocar totalmente y
a rebatir las cartas de la situación
actual en francés pero todos los países
del mundo
por supuesto lo que se fue avanzando
fueron el tema de los transportes y del
sistema económico para poder acoger a
empresas hoy la realidad está más bien
teniendo un una
una vertiente muy diferente porque el
tema del teletrabajo es una realidad y
yo creo que es una realidad que va a
tener dificultad para volver atrás desde
el punto de vista de los asalariados
pero también del punto de vista de las
empresas y se ven por ejemplo hoy la
situación muy compleja de lo que es el
barrio de las de fonz que era una
concentración de oficinas y que hoy
muchas de esas empresas vuelven a parís
porque parte del tiempo que está ocupado
a la repoblación gracias al área dos
están en casa así que no tienen esa
necesidad de estar centralizados en un
lugar eso es un problema de fondo que se
está que se está planteando hoy y que
tenemos que
ver de lo que implica como pérdida de
impuestos de ingresos para el gobierno y
demás hay un punto que se ha desarrollo
ustedes brevemente si es posible el tema
de la especulación
evidentemente como cualquier otro
proyecto de esta magnitud se vive en el
ciclo diciendo que con el apoyo entre si
holzmann el monto a la modernización de
parís a los precios están subiendo
muchísimos ciudades que precisamente
serían beneficiarias de este gran
proyecto ciudades donde hay un sector de
la población muy mal como se hace para
combatir esta situación para evitar que
esa gente al final se quede sin pastel
sin pedazo de pastel si se puede decir
así si incluso de gente que vive y que
tiene y después se siente marginada del
centro de la actividad económica esa es
la única manera de mi punto de vista es
una intervención de estado es decir un
central por lo menos administrativa de
las de las ciudades problemas que en
francés tenemos una una situación que
está heredada de napoleón que los
alcaldes tienen mucho poder y hoy
todavía no está compartido ese poder
sobre el hecho de poder tener
alojamientos sociales y las demandas de
documentos sociales son muy importantes
son hay 500 esperas de demandas del
alojamiento social y 50.000 mil tienen
también las mil demandas tiene tres mil
demandas y 50 mil de propuestas
concretas entonces la realidad es que si
no hay una voluntad
fuerte pero incluso después cuando digo
de estado porque también del estado de
realmente obligar porque hay una
posibilidad que los prefectos puedan
obligar a la construcción de
alojamientos sociales pero ese tema por
ejemplo es un tema de polémicas dentro
parís porque actualmente el gran parís
no tiene esa
esa competencia porque no ha estado
todavía en los estatutos de la gran
parís roberto nos queda menos de un
minuto hay un este proyecto también
implica una gran transformación a nivel
ecológico de manera resumida aparecerán
los principales aportes en buenos hay
cartas label es sobre el tema ecológico
y por ejemplo el tema de las bicicletas
del desplazamiento van a ser elementos
pero en realidad la gente que hace de 20
kilómetros no va a poder estar
trabajando ir a trabajar en bicicleta va
a tomar los transportes públicos y eso
es un elemento importante pero también
hay tema polémico porque por ejemplo
está la zona de diagonales está la zona
de griñón donde él se ha dado hoy la
posibilidad de construir y de poner
hormigón al sitio de
lugares verdes de árboles entonces todo
ese tema así se plantea el tema del
verde pero la realidad todavía no es
totalmente lo que podríamos esperar pues
es una transformación de gran calado en
medio de grandes polémicas como podría
suponerse estamos llegando ya al final a
escala en parís simplemente ustedes
imaginarán que la próxima vez que puedan
venir a parís encontrará muy
probablemente una ciudad muy cambiada y
sobre todo teniendo como trasfondo los
juegos olímpicos del 2024 agradezco a
roberto romero aguilar concejal de la
región isla de francia sobre el proyecto
del gran parís y profesor de economía su
presencia aquí en esta escala gracias
roberto a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita la próxima semana aquí en otra
escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]